Speaker 1: Things have exploded over the Anna
Mae video tweeted out by Republican Congressman
Paul Gosar, in which a cartoon version of
him sort of animate his face on it.
A cartoon, an anime version of Paul Gosar
is depicted as killing Democratic Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.
The demands now ranged from investigate through
a House ethics panel to arrest Paul Gosar
to send the FBI to Paul Gosar to talk to him
about this.
There is also a sort of hypocrisy component
to this, which I'm going to talk about, but
it is a wild, wild story.
So let's start with Newsweek reporting Paul
Gosar faces growing calls to be arrested over
video showing him killing AOC killing AOC.
Congressman Paul Gosar is facing calls to
be arrested or expelled from Congress after
the lawmaker shared an anime video depicting
him killing Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
in most jobs in most jobs.
If it's determined that during your off time,
whatever that means, you are tweeting videos
depicting you killing a coworker.
You would be fired.
OK.
It's just not even.
It's not even.
There's not even a debate about it.
Congressman Gosar sparked fierce backlash
on Sunday after he tweeted an anime video
showing him killing Congresswoman Ocasio-Cortez.
The video, based on the anime attack on Titan,
shows GOES-R killing the New York lawmaker
with a sword before launching himself at President
Joe Biden.
Within hours, the tweet went viral as of Tuesday
morning had been viewed more than 3.2 million
times.
The video and depiction of violence against
AOC led numerous figures to call for Congressman
GOES-R to be arrested or expelled from Congress.
Democrats critics call for action against
Congressman Paul Gosar over his grotesque
post.
This is from Huffington Post.
In any workplace in America, if a coworker
made an anime video killing another coworker,
that person would be fired.
My sentiments?
Exactly.
More than half a dozen House Dems, one House
Republican and scores of critics have condemned
and called for action against Paul Gosar Monday
after he posted a doctored anime video that
depicts him killing Congresswoman AOC.
GOES-R tweeted an edited version of the opening
credits of the Japanese anime series Attack
on Titan, showing himself as the main character
who then slashes the neck of a foe with a
Cosio Cortez's face.
AOC tweeted about it, so while I was en route
to Glasgow, a creepy member I work with who
fundraises for neo-Nazi groups, that's true,
shared a fantasy video of him killing me,
and he'll face no consequences because GOP
leader Kevin McCarthy cheers him on with excuses.
Fun Monday.
Well, back to work.
And then just another aspect to this, which
media matters covered.
GOES-R tweet reveals a double standard in
cable news coverage of extremism and civility
in 2019, cable news devoted more attention
to a Democratic congresswoman cursing than
it's now giving to a Republican congressman,
tweeting an anime video of killing a colleague.
This is a reference to, well, there's a couple
of different things, so first of all, remember
the incident where Steve Scott, a Steve King,
rather embraced white supremacy.
And then there was when Rashida Talib said,
Impeach the mM4.
So you go back and you look at CNN, Fox News
and MSNBC, they all devoted overwhelmingly
more time to Rashida Tlaib cursing versus
Steve King embracing white supremacy.
And we're seeing the point from Media Matters
here is that we're seeing the exact same dynamic
play out with this situation.
Now one other funny thing about Paul Gosar,
and it's not even really that funny.
He has a whole bunch of siblings like it's
one of these families where there's just kids
upon kids, upon kids.
There's a very interesting video where back
in 2018, his siblings endorsed his opponent,
and the ad is very cleverly done where you
don't know until later that these are all
his siblings.
At first, it just kind of sounds like it's
random people saying, I don't like Paul Gosar.
Check this out.
This is this is a good one.
Speaker 2: Paul goes to the congressman isn't
doing anything to help rural America.
Paul's definitely not working for his district.
If they care about health care, they care
about their children's health care.
They would hold them to account if they care
about jobs.
They would hold him to account if he actually
cared about people in rural Arizona.
I bet he'd be fighting for Social Security
for better access to health care.
I better.
I bet he would be researching what is the
most insightful water policy to help the environment
of Arizona sustain itself and be successful.
And he's not listening to you, and he's and
doesn't have your interests at heart.
My name is Tim GOES-R. David GOES-R, Grace,
GOES-R, John GOES-R, Gaston, GOES-R, Jennifer,
GOES-R, Paul Gosar is my brother.
My brother and I endorsed Dr. Bill Dr. Bill
wholeheartedly.
Endorse Dr. David Brill for Congress.
Speaker 1: GOES-R really is one of the most
disgusting members of Congress.
Will there be consequences for tweeting a
video glamorizing drama, dramatizing him,
killing a colleague?
Unfortunately, there probably will not.
There probably
will not.